Michael joins me live now from New York
hello to you Michaels so at what
prompted you to set up this fund I think
like everybody else I was watching
images on the news and online of what
was going on all across Wales all across
you know the UK but particularly South
Wales was was hard hit which is where my
family are where I grew up where a lot
of my life still you know takes place
and and then my family member had to be
evacuated from her home last Sunday
morning she just left with her two dogs
in a pajamas in a boat and and had to
leave all her possessions she couldn't
go back because of health risks around
sewage and so she doesn't know whether
any of her stuff will survive or not
when she'll be able to go back home and
and it really hit home you know so I
thought well I want to do something to
help us as many many people do so I look
to what fundraising pages there might be
and how I might be able to contribute
and I discovered that there are a lot
fun great things going on there's a lot
of effort going on but you know a lot of
it is for very specific groups or
organizations booked places and areas
and so I wanted to see if I could set up
something that was that was for the
whole of Wales and where it could could
get to the places that are hardest hit
and so through the WCB a the Wales
Council for voluntary action that I'm
president of they're in contact with all
the community local community groups and
organisations across Wales so that the
money and then it goes out to where its
most needed so it's been incredible to
see the response of people from all over
the world of people treating and and
I've heard so many messages from people
saying oh I've spent time in males or I
grew up in Wales or you know I've got
family in Wales and and people talking
so warmly about the generosity and the
kindness of people there that they
experience and they want to help out
know themselves so it's been incredible
and people mainly giving sort of 10
pounds 20 pounds here and there and
saying I'm sorry it can't be more but
it's incredibly touching to see how
willing people are to get involved yeah
and and your initial target was 10,000
pounds wasn't it you've more than
trebled that so far and that figure
rising all at the time what difference
can that money make well you know I'm
hearing from people saying things like
you know not only have they been
evacuated from their homes but their
cars obviously have been taken away
their people who still owe money on
their cars and hoping that they'll
they'll get them written off so they can
pay the finance you know the way people
who had their entire home contents in
storage at the time and the storage
places as has just been wiped out so
people you know a lot of people not
insured as well so the effects of what's
happened are gonna go on for a long long
time way beyond and who's this right now
what we're seeing it you know in the
papers people are gonna be dealing with
the effects of this a long long time so
we need to make sure that people are
looked after the people of who want
people to live in their homes have
temporary living and are able to go back
and to have money there to to replace
what they've lost and we need sure the
community services kept up and and there
for people and to help those people on
the front lines who were trying to do
something to help the recovery so that's
what all the money will go towards is
the estimation of the people who are
being affected most and the ones who are
trying to help them the most get that
support